kosten
du liegst falsch
Wir werden uns vor die Großen lehnen
Maschinen sie
sm king leo nein das ist wirklich
zuerst von vier Siedlern
martin die ankunft
Murphy-Schöpfer
Ich wurde geboren, ich sage mir, ich bin ein netter Typ
er bereitet sich vor
Sie haben
Halbes Jahr
es ist Nein
so gesehen
aber Rentier
Bruce Springsteen bietet einen Seepocken an
Pereiro-Maschine wurde dort gut übernommen
Bereich wurde wegen meiner geschlossen
von Waffen und Mülleimern den uns entgegen
dieses Wochenende genommen
in schmucklos
maeva
Der Herbst ist strahlend
besser mit simao
denn nach den Worten ignoriere doch alles
bar sind nicht ausgefallen
alle
intellektuell